- A massive and coordinated
effort to steal this election.
- Electoral fraud that
would be perpetrated
through electronic voting.
- They used the machines to
trash large batches of votes.
- [Narrator] Claims like
these are at the center
of a $1.6 billion defamation
case against Fox News.
Dominion Voting Systems
sued the broadcaster in 2021
over alleged defamatory on-air comments
that tied the company's voting machines
to false claims of election fraud in 2020.
- This case really examines
that line between what is
journalism and what should be protected
and what shouldn't be.
- [Narrator] From internal text messages
to high profile depositions,
here's what you need
to know about the case.
During the 2020 presidential
election, voting machine maker
Dominion had contracts in 28 states.
And after former president
Donald Trump lost,
Fox had his associates on broadcasts.
- Sidney Powell and Rudy Giuliani
claiming that Dominion rigged the election
in favor of President Joe Biden.
- [Narrator] Federal and
state officials have said
there is no evidence that
any voting system deleted
or changed votes during the 2020 election.
The company argues that
by airing those claims,
Fox News gave them prominence,
even though they were false.
Fox says that it was reporting
on newsworthy claims
from a sitting President
and his associates that other
media outlets also covered.
Dominion's main argument is that
Fox News knowingly broadcast false claims
about its machines,
because it had a financial
incentive to do so.
Fox has denied that allegation.
- Many executives in a lot
of these email communications
were expressing
a lot of angst about losing viewership.
- [Narrator] So Dominion
alleges that Fox leaned
into the false claims to keep its viewers.
In released court filings,
Dominion says that
internal communications
among Fox hosts and staff
prove that Fox knew the claims were false,
like a text message from
Tucker Carlson to his producer,
which said, "Sidney Powell is lying."
And another one he sent
to Laura Ingram that said,
"It's unbelievably offensive to me.
Our viewers are good people
and they believe it."
And in her deposition,
Fox host Maria Bartiromo
called an email regarding
the election fraud claims
from Powell, "Kooky and unreliable."
But on her show a day after
receiving the email...
- Sidney, we talked about
the Dominion software.
I know that there were
voting irregularities.
Tell me about that.
- That's to put it mildly.
The computer glitches
could not and should not
have happened at all.
That is where the fraud took place,
where they were flipping votes
in the computer system or
adding votes that did not exist.
- All of these domain will use to say Fox
had a disregard for the facts of the case.
- [Narrator] Fox says
that its on-air hosts
didn't make the Dominion
election fraud claims themselves.
Dominion also released a deposition
from Fox Corporation
Chairman Rupert Murdoch,
who also owns News Corp,
the parent company of
the Wall Street Journal.
- He did acknowledge that
some of the broadcast
did endorse claims of a false election
as opposed to simply reporting on them,
and he acknowledged that
he could have stopped
it from happening.
Fox says that these
quotes were cherry picked
from the deposition, but
those statements on their own,
Dominion will try to use to show that
executives like Rupert Murdoch,
had control over these
decisions that were made on air.
- [Narrator] The judge
said prior to the trial
that he would require Murdoch
and other Fox Corp executives to testify,
if Dominion subpoenaed them.
In a statement, Fox said
demanding witnesses who had nothing to do
with the challenged broadcasts
is just the latest example
of their political crusade
in search of a financial windfall.
Fox also says the lawsuit is
an attack on press freedom.
The 1964 Supreme Court case,
New York Times versus Sullivan,
says that plaintiffs suing for defamation
must be able to prove that the
publisher had actual malice.
- Which means that you knew
that the information was wrong
or you had a reckless
disregard for the truth
in publishing it.
- [Narrator] It's a
historically high bar to meet,
and Fox says that Dominion's
evidence doesn't clear it.
- They say that some of the statements
that have been highlighted,
text messages expressing doubt
were simply cherry picked.
They believe that the host did express,
in some extent, expressed
enough skepticism on air.
- Like here when Tucker Carlson said
he invited Powell to back
up her claims with evidence.
- But she never sent us any evidence
despite a lot of requests,
polite requests, not a page.
- [Narrator] Dominion says
that the emails, texts,
and deposition testimony
speak for themselves.
In late March, Judge
Eric Davis ruled the case
should go to a jury trial.
- The judge also rejected
Fox's arguments that they
should be protected by
the First Amendment,
and that they could have a shield
for reporting allegations neutrally.
- [Narrator] Fox says
that the newsworthiness
of the statements at issue
are clear and indisputable.
The judge also said
that Dominion had proof
that claims the company
had rigged the election
for Joe Biden were false.
Days before the trial was set to begin,
Judge Davis said he was
likely to investigate,
whether Fox News improperly
withheld information during litigation.
He also said Fox might face sanctions.
Fox News said it didn't
improperly withhold information
from Dominion and produced
additional materials,
when it became aware of them.
So the trial will likely
focus on whether Dominion
can prove Fox acted with actual malice,
and if it suffered financial
damages as a result.
- This trial is a rare
example of a defamation case
making it all the way to trial.
And it's particularly important
because Fox News is a huge name in media,
and they have a lot of influence,
and so it'll be in some
ways a test of this
very difficult standard of defamation.
(gentle music)